the ps4 pro will make your games look  better but it's not just new graphical  capability inside the console I'm Tony  and this is your new and improved  GameSpot news update Sony has added an  extra gig of ram to the ps4 pro in an  interview with IGN mark Cerny stated  that this extra ram is d ram which is  slower than the standard gddr5 in the  system this d Ram will be used for  background applications when switching  between apps and games which would  normally be a burden on the regular Ram  by adding a gigabyte of D RAM the ps4  pro can then use its standard Ram to  play your games more smoothly the ps4  pro releases on November 10th for 400  bucks the new console comes with one  terabyte of storage but you'll be able  to swap out for your own hard drive like  usual we'll talk more about the ps4 pro  as we get closer to launch so stay tuned  to game spot for more and for all the  biggest playstation news you're already  in the right place  you